let's go straight now to the white house
where you can see the american president
joel biden about to address the nation
over afghanistan let's listen in
the united states ended
20 years of war in afghanistan
the longest war in american history
we completed one of the biggest airlifts
in history
with more than 120 000 people evacuated
to safety
that number is more than double
what most experts thought were possible
no nation
no nation has ever done anything like it
in all of history
the only united states
had the capacity and the will and
ability to do it and we did it today
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats and
intelligence professionals
for weeks
they risked their lives to get american
citizens
afghans who helped us
citizens of our allies and partners and
others on board planes and out of the
country
and they did it facing a crush of
enormous crowds seeking to leave the
country
and they did it knowing isis-k
terrorists sworn enemies of the taliban
were lurking in the midst of those
crowds
and still
the women and men of the united states
military
our diplomatic corps and intelligence
professionals did their job and did it
well
risking their lives
not for professional gains
but to serve others
not in a mission of war but an admission
of mercy
20 service members were wounded in the
service of this mission
13 heroes gave their lives
i was just at dover air force base
for the dignified transfer
we owe them and their families a debt of
gratitude we can never repay but we
should never ever ever forget
in april
i made a decision to end this war
as part of that decision
we set the date of august 31st for
american troops to withdraw
the assumption was that more than 300
000 afghan national security forces that
we had trained over the past two decades
and equipped
would be a strong adversary
in their civil wars with the taliban
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on for a period of time beyond
military drawdown
turned out not to be accurate
but
i still instructed our national security
team to prepare for every eventuality
even that one and that's what we did
so we were ready
when the afghan security forces after
two decades of fighting for their
country
and losing thousands of their own
did not hold on as long as anyone
expected
we're ready when they
and the people of afghanistan watch
their own government collapse
and the president flee
amid the corruption of malfeasance
handing over the country to their enemy
to taliban
and significantly increasing the risk to
u.s personnel
and our allies
as a result
to safely extract american citizens
before august 31st
as well as embassy personnel
allies and partners
and those afghans who had worked with us
and fought alongside of us for 20 years
i had authorized 6 000
troops american troops to kabul
to help secure the airport
as general mckenzie said
this is the way the mission was designed
it was designed to operate under severe
stress and
attack and that's what it did
since march
we reached out 19 times to americans
in afghanistan
with multiple warnings
and offers to help them leave
afghanistan all the way back as far as
march
after we started the evacuation 17 days
ago
we did initial outreach and analysis
and identified around 5 000 americans
who had decided earlier to stay in
afghanistan
but now
wanted to leave
our operation allied rescue
ended up getting more than 5
500 americans out
we got out thousands of citizens and
diplomats
from those countries that went to into
afghanistan with us to get bin laden
we got out locally employed staff for
the united states embassy and their
families totaling roughly 2
500 people
we got thousands of afghan translators
and interpreters
and others who supported the united
states out as
well now we believe that about 100 to
200 americans remain in afghanistan
with some intention
to leave
most of those who remain
are dual citizens
long-time residents who had earlier
decided to stay
because of their family roots in
afghanistan
the bottom line
90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
and for those remaining americans
there is no deadline
we remain committed to get them out if
they want to come out
secretary state blinken
is leading the continued diplomatic
efforts to ensure safe passage for any
american
afghan partner or foreign national
who wants to leave afghanistan
in fact just yesterday
the united nations security council
passed a resolution
that sent a clear message about the
international community expects the
taliban to deliver on moving forward
notably
freedom of travel freedom to leave and
together
we are joined by over 100 countries
that are determined to make sure that
taliban upholds those commitments
it will include ongoing efforts in
afghanistan to reopen the airport as
well as overland routes
allowing for continued departure
to those who want to leave
and deliver humanitarian assistance to
the people of afghanistan
the taliban has made public commitments
broadcast on television
and radio across afghanistan
unsafe passage for anyone wanting to
leave including those who worked
alongside americans
we don't take them by their word alone
but by their actions
and we have leverage to make sure those
commitments are met
let me be clear
leaving august the 31st
is not due to an arbitrary deadline
it was designed to save american lives
my predecessor the former president
signed an agreement with the taliban
to remove u.s troops by may the first
just months after i was inaugurated
it included no requirement that taliban
work out a cooperative governing
arrangement
with the afghan government
but it did authorize the release
of 5 000 prisoners last year
including some of the taliban's top war
commanders
among those
who just took control of afghanistan
and by the time i came to office
the taliban was in his strongest
military position
since 2001
controlling or contesting nearly half of
the country
the previous administration's agreement
said
that if we stuck to the may first
deadline that they had signed on to
leave by
the taliban wouldn't attack any american
forces
but if we stayed
all bets were off
so we're left with a simple decision
either follow through on the commit made
by the last administration and leave
afghanistan
or say we weren't leaving and commit
another tens of thousands more troops
going back to war
that was the choice the real choice
between leaving or escalating
i was not going to extend this forever
war
and i was not extending a forever exit
the decision to end the military lift
operations at kabul airport was based on
the unanimous
recommendation of my civilian and
military advisors
the secretary of state
the secretary of defense
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff and all the service chiefs
and the commanders in the field
their recommendation
was that the safest way to secure the
passage of the remaining americans and
others
out of the country
was not to continue with 6 000 troops on
the ground in harm's way in kabul
but rather to get them out through
non-military means
in the 17 days
that we operated in kabul
after the taliban seized power we
engaged in an around-the-clock effort to
provide every american
the opportunity to leave
our state department was working 24 7
contacting and talking
and in some cases walking
americans into the airport
again
more than 5
500 americans were airlifted out
and for those who remain
we will make arrangements to get them
out if they so choose
as for the afghans
we and our partners have airlifted 100
000 of them
no country in history has done more to
airlift out the residents of another
country than we have done
we will continue
to work to help more people leave the
country who are at risk
we're far from done
for now
i urge all americans
to join me in grateful prayer
for our troops and diplomats and
intelligence officers
who carried out this mission of mercy
in kabul
and a tremendous risk with such
unparalleled results
an airmen an airlift
that evacuated tens of
thousands to a network of volunteers and
veterans
who helped identify those needing
evacuation
guide them to the airport
and provided them for their support
along the way
we're going to continue to need their
help
we need your help and i'm looking
forward to meeting with you
and to everyone
who is now offering or who will offer to
welcome afghan allies to their homes
around the world including in america
we thank you
i take responsibility for the decision
now some say
we should have started mass evacuation
sooner
and couldn't this have been done had
been done in a more orderly manner
i respectfully disagree
imagine
if we've begun evacuations in june or
july
bringing in thousands of american troops
and evacuating more than 120 000 people
in the middle of a civil war
there still would have been a rush to
the airport
a breakdown of confidence and control of
the government
and it still would have been very
difficult and dangerous mission
the bottom line is
there is no evacuation evacuation
from the end of a war
that you can run without the kinds of
complexities
challenges threats we faced none
those who would say we should have
stayed indefinitely
for years on end
they asked why don't we just keep doing
what we were doing
why do we have to change anything
the fact is
everything had changed
my predecessor had made a deal with the
taliban
when i came into office we faced a
deadline may 1.
the taliban onslaught was coming
we faced one of two choices
follow the agreement of the previous
administration
and extend it to have or extend
to have more time for people to get out
or send in thousands of more troops
and escalate the war
to those
asking for a third decade of war in
afghanistan i ask
what is the vital national interest
in my view we only have one
make sure afghanistan can never be used
again to launch an attack on our
homeland
remember why we went to afghanistan in
the first place
because we were attacked by osama bin
laden and al qaeda
on september 11
2001
and they were based in afghanistan
we delivered justice to bin laden on may
2
2011.
over a decade ago
al-qaeda was decimated
i respectfully suggest you ask yourself
this question
if we'd been attacked on september 11
2001
from yemen
instead of afghanistan
would we have ever gone to war in
afghanistan
even though the taliban controlled
afghanistan in the year 2001
i believe the honest answer is no
that's because we had no vital interest
in afghanistan other than to prevent an
attack
on america's homeland and their friends
and that's true today
we succeeded in what we set out to do in
afghanistan over a decade ago
then we stayed for another decade
it was time to end this war
this is a new world
the terror threat has metastasized
across the world well beyond afghanistan
we face threats from al-shabaab in
somalia
al-qaeda affiliates in syria and the
arabian peninsula
and isis attempting to create a kayla
fight in syria and iraq and establishing
affiliates across africa and asia
the fundamental obligation of a
president in my opinion
is to defend and protect america
not against threats of 2001
but against the threats of 2021 and
tomorrow
that is the guiding principle behind my
decisions about afghanistan
i simply do not believe
that the safety and security of america
is enhanced by continuing to deploy
thousands of american troops
and spending billions of dollars a year
in afghanistan
but i also know
that the threat from terrorism continues
in its pernicious and evil nature
but it's changed
expand it to other countries
our strategy has to change too
we will maintain the fight against
terrorism afghanistan and other
countries
we just don't need to fight
a ground war to do it
we have what's called over the horizon
capabilities
which means we can strike terrorists and
targets without american boots on the
ground or very few if needed
we've shown that capacity just in the
last week
we struck isis k remotely
days after they murdered 13 of our
service members
and dozens of innocent afghans
and to isis k
we are not done with you yet
as commander-in-chief
i firmly believe the best path to guard
our safety and our security lies in a
tough
unforgiving targeted precise strategy
that goes after terror where it is the
day
not where it was two decades ago
that's what's in our national interest
and here's a critical thing to
understand
the world is changing
we're engaged in a serious competition
with china
we're dealing with the challenges on
multiple fronts with russia
we're confronted with cyber attacks
and nuclear proliferation
we have to shore up america's
competitive to meet these new challenges
in the competition for the 21st century
and we can do both
fight terrorism
and take on new threats that are here
now and will continue to be here in the
future
and there's nothing china or russia
would rather have would want more
in this competition in the united states
to be bogged down another decade in
afghanistan
as we turn the page
on the foreign policy
that's guided our nation our nation the
last two decades
we've got to learn from our mistakes
to me there are two that are paramount
first
we must set
missions with clear
achievable goals
not ones we'll never reach
and second
we must stay clearly focused on the
fundamental national security interest
of the united states of america
this decision about afghanistan
is not just about afghanistan
it's about ending an era
of major military operations
to remake other countries
we saw a mission
of counter-terrorism in afghanistan
getting the terrorists and stopping
attacks
morph into a counter-insurgency
nation-building
trying to create a democratic cohesive
in united afghanistan something that has
never been done over many centuries of
afghan's history
moving on from that mindset
and those kind of large-scale troop
deployments will make us stronger and
more effective and safer at home
and for anyone who gets the wrong idea
let me say clearly
to those who wish america harm
to those who engage in terrorism against
us or our allies know this
the united states will never rest
we will not forgive will not forget
we'll hunt you down to the ends of the
earth and we will you will pay the
ultimate price
and let me be clear
we'll continue to support the afghan
people through diplomacy
international influence and humanitarian
aid we'll continue to push
for regional diplomacy engagement to
prevent violence and instability
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people
especially women and girls as we speak
out for women and girls all around the
globe
and i've been clear
that human rights will be the center of
our foreign policy
but the way to do that is not through
endless military deployments
but through diplomacy economic tools and
rallying the rest of the world for
support
my fellow americans
the war in afghanistan is now over
i'm the fourth president
who has faced the issue of whether and
when to end this war
when i was running for president
i made a commitment to the american
people that i would end this war
today i've honored that commitment
it was time to be honest with the
american people again
we no longer had a clear purpose in an
open-ended mission in afghanistan
after 20 years of war in afghanistan i
refuse to send another generation of
america's sons and daughters
to fight a war
that should have ended long ago
after more than two trillion dollars
spent in afghanistan
of course the researchers of brown
university estimated
would be over
300 million dollars a day for 20 years
in afghanistan for two decades
yes
the american people should hear this 300
million dollars a day for two decades
you take the number of one trillion as
many say
that's still 150 million dollars a day
for two decades
and what have we lost as a consequence
in terms of opportunities i refuse to
continue to war that was no longer in
the service of the vital national
interests of our people
and most of all
after 800 000 americans
serving in afghanistan i've traveled
that whole country
brave and honorable service
after 20
744 american servicemen and women
injured and the loss of 2
461 american personnel including 13
lives
lost just this week
i refuse to open another decade of
warfare in afghanistan
we've been a nation too long at war
if you're 20 years old today
you've never known an america at peace
so when i hear
that we could have should have
continued the so-called low-grade effort
in afghanistan
at low risk to our service members at
low cost
i don't think enough people understand
how much we have asked of the one
percent of this country
who put that uniform on
willing to put their lives on the line
in defense of our nation
maybe it's because my deceased son beau
served in iraq for a full year before
that
well
maybe it's because of what i've seen
over the years
as senator vice president and president
traveling these countries
a lot of our veterans and their families
have gone through hell
deployment after deployment
months and years away from their
families
miss birthdays
anniversaries empty chairs of holidays
financial struggles divorces
loss of limbs traumatic brain injury
post-traumatic stress
we see it in the struggles
many have when they come home
we see in the strain on their families
and caregivers
we see in the strain of their families
when they're not there
we see it in the grief borne by their
survivors
a cost of war
they will carry with them
their whole lives
most tragically
we see in the shocking and stunning
statistic
that should give pause to anyone who
thinks
war can ever be low grade
low risk or low cost
18 veterans on average
who die by suicide every
single day in america
not in a far-off place
but right here in america
there's nothing low grade or low risk or
low cost about any war
it's time to end the war in afghanistan
as we close 20 years of war and strife
and pain and sacrifice
it's time to look at the future
not the past
to future that's safer
to future that's more secure
to future that honors those who served
and all those who gave what president
lincoln called
their last full measure of devotion
i gave my word with all of my heart
i believe
this is the right decision
a wise decision
and the best decision for america
thank you
thank you and may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
if you're just joining us here live on
al jazeera we have been listening to
president biden talk about his reasoning
for the withdrawal from afghanistan we
he concluded by basically saying we've
been a nation too long at war and he
wants everybody to forget the shoulda
woulda coulda he continued to say i take
responsibility for the decision and he
said i disagree with those people who
say that it could have been done better
he said it would still have been
dangerous and difficult for the u.s to
withdraw at any time let's go to alan
fisher who's live at the white house for
us alan it sounded when president biden
started talking like it was kind of his
school report and he was giving himself
an a or a gold star in every column
but just take us through all the
different things that he said and what
you make of of his report card
the problem he's got is that they're
still americans in afghanistan that
aside
joe biden did what he had to do here he
laid out what in his view was the
foreign policy he took a while to get to
it but when he said my fellow americans
the war in afghanistan is over
he made reference to donald trump twice
without actually mentioning him talking
about the previous administration and
the deal that was done with the taliban
and how uh to a degree without actually
using the words that he felt box then
that they had set a date of may 31st for
the withdrawal of all american troops
and he was faced uh with the prospect
that people wouldn't get out in time
which is why he extended it remember
initially he extended it till the 11th
of september
that was seen as inappropriate and he
moved it forward to august the 31st
what is interesting is that
his view was they either had to extend
that deadline or escalate the war that
was important they would have to put
thousands and thousands more troops into
afghanistan to make sure that the
operation
could be carried out
he said
the reason that he wanted to pull out
excuse me was because they did what they
went to afghanistan to do a decade ago
when they killed osama bin laden back in
in late april early may 2011 and he said
it was important that people recognize
that and then he turned his attention of
course to the fact that there are still
americans he pointed to the fact that
since march they've made 19 different
contacts with people 19 times they've
reached out to americans who were in
afghanistan and told them of the plans
to evacuate them many of them decided to
stay he said that 5 500 americans and
their families had been brought out of
the country there was perhaps one to 200
who were still uh still in afghanistan
in his view
you know that there's facilities there
to get them out they will work hard
to facilitate that obviously alongside
the taliban but he did say that many of
these people may well be dual citizens
people who have decided that they are
staying in afghanistan because of family
roots he talked about the loss that the
united states has suffered not just in
terms of the number of people who had
been killed but also financially seeing
three trillion dollars or 300 million
dollars every day for the last 20 years
and how that simply couldn't go on and
how they will change the way that they
monitor afghanistan this over the
horizon view that they will keep an eye
on potential threats coming to the
american homeland from afghanistan from
a safe distance and on those threats
he's
specific words for isil k the group that
was behind the attack at the airport in
afghanistan just less than a week ago
and he made it clear to them he said
isis k
we are not done with you yet so that was
a very clear warning to isil
this wouldn't satisfy republicans who
have been highly critical of joe biden
for being an american president who
abandoned and that's the word they will
use abandoned americans and afghanistan
but joe biden speaks to the nation
knowing that there was a poll out just a
couple of hours ago that said 54 of
americans support the decision
to pull out of afghanistan not many not
that number think that joe biden did a
good job but it's something that will be
forgotten and as joe biden made
reference to a couple of times he said
that he would pull american troops out
of afghanistan that was one of his
pledges when he was running for
president he will be able to say that he
has delivered on this promise even
though republicans will still use the
fact that there are americans in
afghanistan as the political stake to
beat joe biden it was perhaps
as good as joe biden could have done in
the circumstances and certainly
you saw that he wanted to make sure that
there was never another generation
committed to a war in afghanistan that
he said simply
had no defined mission and that is why
the united states needed to leave
afghanistan alan do you think for those
people who believe that this uh
withdrawal was a mess that it was badly
planned that it was clumsy will they be
convinced by the reasoning that biden
just delivered
uh no if you if you don't think that joe
biden did a good job on this you're not
going to be convinced you're not going
to sit and listen
uh in a measured way and think that the
president delivered a recent argument
simply because
politics in america is now
very polarized and it's rare that
someone can be converted over to a
thinking the other way by a reasoned or
well put together constructive argument
and that will certainly be the case here
this is really joe biden
saying to those who may be undecided
look
it's better to be out of afghanistan
than in it's cheaper to be out of
afghanistan than in it is safer for
american service men and women to be out
of afghanistan rather than in and at
some point the decision had to be made
given a deal was already done and he
made reference to that deal that the
trump administration uh had done with
the taliban who said look there was a
deal done and this is true there was a
deal done with the taliban that said we
will pull the american troops out by
this date and that was may the 31st but
there was nothing in that deal that said
the taliban by that date had to be
involved in a coalition government with
the the existing afghan government or a
government of national unity there was
no term put to the taliban that if you
if we do this then you must do that
and he believes that that was a failing
in the deal and that is something that
republicans who have been attacking joe
biden over the last few weeks have
conspicuously failed uh to mention so
joe biden believes that what he did
he did with the best intentions and in
the circumstances that were presented to
him as he walked into the oval office on
january the 20th alan fisher they're
joining us with the very latest live
from the white house after off the back
of that
president biden address alan thanks very
much